But husband's HSCRP was elevated and what that means is high sensitivity, CE reactive protein or some labs call it cardiac CRP.
And because when that fast test first came out, they thought it was going to be much more specific to cardiovascular issues.
And you could argue that it probably is a little bit more specific to cardiovascular issues.
But there's so many things that could cause elevated high sensitivity CRP.
Any inflammation in your body could cause it. Certainly cardiac issues.
Well, you could even have dental infections causing, you know, hidden dental infections causing elevated CRP.
Brain inflammation could cause elevated CRP, Alzheimer's, Parkinson's, abdominal, you know, got issues can cause elevated CRP.
Obesity can cause elevated CRP. There's a lot of things that can cause that. So investigating other things.
Just like any lab marker, it's not a standalone thing.
You have this, that means this. You have elevated PSA. That's pretty much means you have prostate cancer.
Most markers aren't standalone. You have to look at it in conjunction with other things as well.